en este vídeo vamos a aprender algunas
cosas acerca de razones le voy a poner
aquí arriba razones razón es una razón
entre dos cantidades es básicamente una
forma en la cual podemos compararlas
eso suena un poco sofisticado así que
déjame poner algunos ejemplos
imagínate que tengo 10 caballos le voy a
poner 10 caballos
y que tengo cinco perros cinco perros
y que alguien me pregunta por la razón
que existe entre la cantidad de caballos
y la cantidad de perros que tengo lo voy
a poner aquí arriba nos preguntan por la
razón razón de caballos
bajos
a perros
perros perros bueno si alguien me
pregunta por la razón de caballos a
perros lo que tengo que decir es cuántos
caballos tengo por cada perro y eso lo
puedo escribir numéricamente como sigue
como tengo diez caballos y cinco perros
entonces puedo decir que la razón de
caballos a perros es 10 a 5 y eso se
escribe así 10 2 puntos 2 puntos 5 es
decir tengo 10 caballos por cada 5
perros que tengo esto también se puede
escribir como fracción si lo escribo
como 10 entre 5 o bien lo podemos
escribir con letras como 10
5 vale ok entonces observa que lo
primero que ponemos es caballos porque
nos interesa la razón de caballos a
perros
entonces aquí tengo caballos
y aquí tengo caballos siempre al
principio y por otro lado tengo perros
que es el segundo objeto entonces eso
viene en segundo lugar en cualquiera de
estas expresiones vale bueno ahora qué
significa realmente esto de que la razón
de caballos a perros sea 10 a 5 bueno
pues eso es prácticamente decir que
tengo 2 caballos por cada perro verdad
si tengo 5 perros y 10 caballos entonces
hay dos caballos por cada perro entonces
podemos simplificar esto podemos cambiar
la razón y decir que la razón de
caballos a perros es 2 2 a 1 y esto es
totalmente equivalente a los de aquí
arriba vale como dice para obtener este
2 a 1 pues simplemente me fijo en cuál
es la máxima cantidad o el número más
grande que divide a 10 ya 5 y hago la
división tengo que encontrar el máximo
común divisor aquí el máximo común
divisor de 10 y 5 es 5 10 entre 52 y 55
es 1 y entonces aquí tenemos una versión
simplificada del
la razón es decir para una razón no
tenemos que poner literalmente la
cantidad de cada cosa que tenemos sino
simplemente como estar relacionadas
estas dos cantidades vale bueno otra
forma de poner esto mismo sería como dos
a uno así en fracción o bien si lo
ponemos escrito es 2 a 1 y esto quiere
decir que tengo dos caballos por cada
perro que tengo ahora qué sucedería qué
sucedería si alguien me pregunta por la
razón de perros a caballos lo voy a
preguntar en color verde la razón la
razón de perros
ross
perros y caballos cada varios bueno pues
ahora tenemos que voltear los números
verdad si la razón de caballos a perros
es 10 a 5 entonces la razón de perros a
caballos es 5 a 10 pero podemos ponerlo
como expresión simplificada así verdad
como 1 a 2 entonces en este caso lo que
tendría es que las razones 1
a 2 o también lo podemos poner como 1 a
2 así o escribir simplemente 1 a 2 y
entonces esto lo que quiere decir es que
tengo un perro por cada 2 caballos que
tengo lo estamos poniendo en forma
simplificada porque esa es la convención
o sea esta es una forma válida de
escribir la razón está también pero es
preferible la de abajo porque está usa
números más chiquitos está simplificada
bueno creo que ya le va escuchando a la
idea vamos a ver otro ejemplo imagínate
que tenemos este va a ser un ejemplo de
frutas
imagínate que tenemos 20 manzanas 20
manzanas
nada más
que tenemos 40 naranjas 40 naranjas
naranjas
y que tenemos 60 fresas bueno voy a
poner que son peras para usar el color
verde 60 peras
entonces qué sucedería lo que tendría
que hacer si alguien me pregunta por la
razón de naranjas de manzanas naranjas o
fresas lo voy a escribir entonces
imagínate que queremos la razón razón de
manzanas manzanas naranjas
a naranjas
a peras a peras
bueno pues para encontrar la razón de
manzanas a naranjas a peras
lo primero que hago es escribir estos
números que sería 20
a 40
a 40 a 60 a 60 y esto sería una forma
totalmente válida de escribir la razón
pero que podemos reducir tenemos que
encontrar el mayor número que divide a
veinte cuarenta y sesenta y ese número
es 20 entonces lo que voy a hacer de
aquí para abajo es dividir entre 20 de
aquí para acá voy a dividir entre 20
para simplificar esta razón observa que
necesitamos encontrar un número que
divida a los tres números ya no a dos de
ellos porque como queremos simplificar
la razón hay que dividir todos los
números by bueno dividiendo entre 20 me
queda que las razones 1
a 2
a 3 a 3 entonces la razón de manzanas
naranjas peras es 1 a 2 a 3 muy bien me
parece que vas entendiendo cada vez
mejor la idea qué sucedería si nos piden
esta razón al revés por ejemplo qué
sucede si nos piden la razón de peras
peras a naranjas a naranjas
a manzanas a manzanas bueno pues en este
caso si importa el orden tenemos que
poner primero el número correspondiente
a peras luego el de naranjas y luego el
de manzanas aquí está simplificado
entonces lo ponemos como 3 a 2 a 2 a 1 a
1 entonces es importante verdad cuando
hablamos de razón es saber cuál número
va primero el correspondiente a qué
objeto aquí como esperas a naranjas a
manzanas tenemos que hacer 60 a 40 a 20
que se simplifica como 3 a 2 a 1 muy
bien vamos para aquí abajo para ahora
hacer un problema de razones y empezar a
jugar un poco con con ejercicios sale
imagínate que tenemos un salón de clases
y ahora vamos a intentar hacerlo que lo
que hicimos arriba arriba pero al revés
ahora nos van a dar una razón y queremos
encontrar un cierto número entonces en
este salón de clases sabemos que la
razón de niños a niñas lo voy a poner
aquí
la razón
de niños niños
a niñas a niñas
niñas
es es 2 a 3
dos tercios también lo podemos lo
podemos poner así verdad dos a tres
sabemos esto sabemos más información
sabemos que en el salón hay 40
estudiantes ahí
hay 40 estudiantes en total
tu día antes es decir contando niños y
niñas estudiantes
estudiantes y lo que nos piden es cuál
es la cantidad de niñas que hay cuántas
niñas hay
cuántas cuántas niñas
y niñas
ay cuántas niñas hay muy bien
imagínate que queremos responder esta
pregunta este problema se ve un poco más
complicado de lo que hemos hecho aquí
arriba pero una vez más simplemente
tenemos que utilizar esto de las razones
si nos están diciendo que la razón de
niños a niñas es 2 a 3 entonces eso se
puede escribir así se puede escribir
como niños
niños
dividido entre niñas
niñas
es igual a 2 entre 3 2 entre 3 pero
observa que esto nos da otra información
esto nos dice cuántos niños y cuántas
niñas hay cada 5 estudiantes si sumamos
estos 2 con estos 3 tenemos 5
estudiantes y de ahí 2 son niños y 3 son
niñas entonces voy a escribirlo por acá
esta información esta información nos
dice nos dice que que de cada 5
estudiantes de cada
5 estudiantes 5 estudiantes
día antes
dos son niños son niños
y 33 son niñas niñas y esta información
esta fabulosa porque si sabemos que de
cada cinco estudiantes dos son niños y
tres son niñas entonces vas a ver
cuántos grupos de 5 estudiantes hay en
el salón de clases y después multiplicar
esa cantidad de grupitos de 5 por 3 para
encontrar la cantidad de niñas vamos a
hacer eso lo primero que vamos a hacer
es ver cuántos grupos de 40 estudiantes
hay entonces si tenemos 40 lo voy a
poner aquí 40 estudiantes y esta y
tenemos que ver cuántos grupos de 5 hay
hay que dividir entre 55 estudiantes por
grupo por grupo o por pues si por
grupito de 5 y esto es igual a
estudiantes se cancela con estudiantes
las unidades nos quedan grupos grupos de
5 de 5 estudiantes
estudiantes le voy a poner así y 40
entre 5 nos queda 8 entonces hay 8
grupos de 5 estudiantes y ya sabiendo
cuántos grupos de 5 estudiantes hay pues
ya nada más tenemos que utilizar la
información de que en cada grupo de 5
hay 3 niñas entonces tenemos lo voy a
poner aquí arriba a la derecha tenemos
debemos
tenemos 8 por 3 que es igual a 24 niñas
niñas
sale otra vez como le dice simplemente
vi cuántos grupos de 5 estudiantes había
como son cuales 40 estudiantes hay 8
grupos de 5 y en cada grupo de 5 hay 3
niñas entonces son 3 niñas por 8 grupos
3 por 8 es 24 de esta forma en total hay
24 niñas y a partir de aquí podemos
hacer lo mismo con la cantidad de niños
o bien podemos encontrarlo de otra forma
si ya sabemos que hay 8 grupos de 5
estudiantes y hay dos niños en cada
grupo de 5 entonces hay 2 por 8 o sea 16
niños 8 por 2 que es igual a 16 niños
eso es una forma de hacerlo
o bien otra forma en la siguiente ya
sabemos la cantidad de niñas que hay que
son 24 en total hay 40 estudiantes
entonces ya los 40 estudiantes les
quitamos las 24 niñas obtenemos los 16
16 niños muy bien entonces así podemos
resolver este problema ahorita lo
hicimos un poco más largo de lo que
sería usualmente usualmente pues nada
más hay que dividir 40 entre 5 ese 5
viene de dos más tres vale entonces
hacemos dos más tres queda cinco
entonces hay que dividir en grupos de 5
8 en 340 entre 5 sería 8 40 entre 5
sería igual a 8 entonces hay 8 grupos y
ya nada más multiplicamos 8 por 2 por 8
por 3 porque en cada grupo hay tres
niñas 3 por 8 es 24 muy bien esto sería
la forma rápida de hacerlo vamos a otro
problema un poquito más complicado vamos
aquí y vamos a pensar ahora en una
granja
van imagínate qué nos dicen que la razón
lo voy a poner en color rosa la razón
de animales en una granja es la
siguiente ovejas ovejas
la razón de ovejas
pollos
qué más hay en una granja vamos a
ponerles cerdos la razón de ovejas
apoyos a cerdos
2 imagínate que nos dicen que es igual a
2 a 5 a 10 todos a 5
a 10 muy bien entonces aquí tenemos la
razón y nos dicen además que en total
hay 51 animales total total 51 animales
animales
y nos preguntan cuántos pollos hay
cuántos pollos
cuantos
pollos
hoyos bueno pues vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo que hicimos arriba
a ver aquí tenemos una vez más que
dividir en en grupitos como lo hacemos
para saber en grupitos de qué tamaño
tenemos que hacerlo pues sumamos dos más
cinco más 10 25 10 es 17 2 más 5 más 10
es igual a 17 de modo que en cada grupo
de 17 hay dos ovejas cinco pollos y diez
cerdos ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
dividir el total de animales entre 17
para ver cuántos grupos tenemos entonces
sería 51 el total de animales dividido
entre 17 esto lo que nos da es tres
grupos
grupos grupos de 17 de 17 y ya sabiendo
que tenemos tres grupos de 17 y que en
cada grupo de 17 hay cinco pollos
entonces en total hay tres por cinco o
sea quince pollos no voy a poner en
color amarillo de pollos entonces hay
hay tres por cinco que es igual a quince
pollos pollos muy bien otra vez lo que
hacemos es sumar todos estos números nos
queda 17 entonces ahora hacemos grupos
de 17 como son 51 animales hay tres
grupos de 17 en cada uno de estos tres
hay cinco pollos y por lo tanto hay tres
por cinco o sea quince pollos y se puede
hacer exactamente lo mismo para
encontrar la cantidad de ovejas y de
cerdos